yeah welcome to this video playing mr.
white from the US and actually I forgot
no mr. white was in that movie maybe you
can help me ok ok we have a nympho
Rubenstein that he took on c3 um without
being really provoked to do so this is
this in fact a line that is sometimes
played and I considered it form for my
book project but at the end I I felt
that it's not solid enough it's probably
playable but it still feels we had to
give a perm or to get into a damaged
structure without white having lost to
move ok I'm just pushing my pawns here
to get them
as Muslim pawn presence in the center as
possible and for young e 5 maybe maybe
you should play 25 not sure but at some
point you need to put upon in the center
I mean this is the the NIMS Oh myth that
you can play this opening without
putting points in the center at the end
you need to otherwise you're steamrolled
okay yeah Knight f3 knight to c6 the
question is should I just castle on the
Sherpa geforce this is a problem
I could also take and play Bishop g5
this is also not bad probably but you
can take on deform then 5 hmm now let's
let's castle thrust I don't think that
Bishop g4 is such a such a big issue Wow
one but now I do with had this this
really looks terrible
is in this in this dreadful pin I can
just take a plane 95
yeah this is just the central pawn
yeah black needs to protect this night
where to go Queen e6 or queen d6y am the
questions if that's even something
better what's c5 I mean better than just
take end and play this position c5 takes
bishop a six-night takes a 50 night xe5
and funny and c5 takes something else
don't know
let's just take that I don't I didn't
see anything maybe I'm just just blind
but this is the porn at the center enter
really should be should be very good
and they have a very natural plan to
pile up on the air file and get pieces
towards the king with rook f4 look f-105
rookie for this kind of moves
yeah maybe maybe is yeah but f5 really
it's not really to really a problem f5 I
can just play you five and it doesn't
really help him
no f5 is even hanging okay he's got c4
and returned it again this is not I just
play look everyone next move and
if he takes this through FC I know
that's not rogue f6 and we'll get sixy
can take twice because of the pin but ok
g4s not been anyway if he takes I can
also simply take G form it's not not bad
at all is this something better
this is okay keep it simple 36 is really
weak
I may be better up c 8 and then G form
and they are not really a problem I
could have considered this a bit more
g-form hmm g-form maybe
yeah this is simple probably n to n
divided
the exchanges takes on edge form I
should be able to to win the end game
check
wait not not too quickly let's let's
think about this for a moment at least
what is the simplest way to do that
maybe maybe Bishop to g4 then I need to
pick up the pawns
okay but this this is pro Nia fine
anyway
hmm
okay it's playing Bishop 86 know
we should be six was very likely better
and now i think i can pick up the pawns
but I probably played this very badly
visual basics was I think perfectly I
ride for life
here this should be a six okay i can i
can drop back and still I mean if anyone
can try something here it's Wyatt but
not sure if I'm really winning hmm
probably this was really bad plan
yeah look g3 is much stronger
yeah this is the problem now it's very
strong black has no way to defend that
yeah this was much better
yeah then this puzzle right I just need
to need to play that this gifts gives
away almost all advantage so it's still
something I mean but it's not winning
probably all right thanks for watching